so today with what's going on you said
something he said the secular movement
you said 200 years ago i would say
probably woodrow wilson when they took
bible out of school and people stopped
having to go through some of the things
so for me it would be 117 years ago
maybe but let's just say you're saying
200 years ago fine
um
the secular movement where
man
fears a higher power less it's like ah
whatever you know yeah i get it it's
totally fine i'm not you know sure we're
no longer seeing hey you know president
get up and you know give us a prayer or
you go to school and prayer and you know
whether you believe or not the power of
prayer is a way of telling a kid that
hey there's somebody that's watching
over you where you're by yourself
and you're fearing you don't have to
commit suicide because you can pray and
speak to somebody you are not by
yourself somebody has your back if i
just see the side effects of the
direction we're going without a god
whether it's true or not because you
know the way i look at it is i look at
if you start a country let's just say
you start a country today and the five
is going to start a country you're going
to be the president
i'm going to be a general of a military
he's going to be the one that's checking
everyone's ids to see what you know how
good looking they are whatever
kai's going to do different job tyler's
going to do a different job
you know
would i build my country on a foundation
of a faith or without it i think whether
people believe in the faith or not to
build it on a foundation of a faith is
going to have a higher chances of doing
better than one not being built on a
certain set of values and principles
because if you don't then people are
going to create their own set of values
and principles so if we're not living by
the same set of values and principles
and i don't have to meet your values and
principles i don't care what you believe
in i don't believe in what you believe
in so i don't have to be committed to
your values and principles i can do
whatever the hell i want to do i don't
care if i earn your loyalty or your
trust or your relationship
then there's that confusion right so
for somebody like yourself because you
know that whole thing you you know you
said this on the last podcast you know
you know
strong leaders build good times good
leaders build you know weak leaders weak
leaders build bad times bad leaders
build strongly and that cold things
going do you think your generation
now your fathers do you think your
generation is a generation of strong
leaders
my generation no exceptionally weak
leaders so so isn't it
okay so
so
and i i'm
you said that so if that's the case and
that's what you're saying what do you
think is the responsibility of your
generation
to share with maybe our generation so we
don't continue that
you know uh same you know so we can
learn something so say hey you guys got
to pay attention to xyz let me tell you
what's going on right now in the world
specifically in america i've been in
paris for 25 years i've been watching
guys from the outside
the america i'm used to is america used
to be
but today's
you guys got to be careful with these
five things you have zero interest in so
that's not a question you're going to
get me to answer you know that no i
don't know that no of course i mean how
can i appear gamble a little bit
no how can i appear as a prophet do i
have anything
profit no it's a prophetic task
no but i'm talking look no look for
example okay
say if he's dating a girl okay
uh and he says pat
he hasn't done it yet but if he says pat
this is the first time i'm asking you
for a double date because i want to get
your opinion on it he's never asked me
which means what he's never dated a girl
that's that serious okay he's never
asked me but the day comes when he asked
me
i want to go on a double date i think
this thing's getting a little bit
serious i want to get your feedback on
it okay
so we go
and i meet her
and we walk away and he says so what do
you think and i had a two and a half
hour dinner with her so i really got a
chance that she sat right in front of me
and he sat right in front of my wife so
they're talking and i'm learning about
her right
and uh what do you think
and i say
you know
i would suggest pop-up i really like
their energy i think you guys going to
be good but
you know
i take my time i would give some kind of
counsel as a friend to look at for my
friend my brother right i would give
some kind of a counsel to say here's
it's not necessarily prophetic
but it's more counsel to say
odds wise the odds are son
here's what i would do before you get
married the odds are
if you want to take care i've been a
financial advisor for 20 plus years
right i don't sit with a client and
saying guaranteed we're going to get you
12
i can't say guaranteed you're going to
heaven guaranteed america is going to be
better i'm asking you based on odds and
your wisdom and your life what do you
tell us what can we be prepared for
because we don't want to get another
bathtub if you want to go out and
introduce me to your girlfriend i'll
give you my honesty
[Laughter]
if you want
my wisdom my inexpressible wisdom about
the cost of american society
and a recommendation for what we
collectively should be doing i have to
discourage you i don't have that
i don't have that why are you playing
safe though david why are you playing so
safe
i don't know why you know you said
something earlier you said uh
you know the level of interest in people
in me right now is you know like versus
what it used to be at this age i'm the
opposite like i enjoy talking to people
when their age starts with an eight
i don't know i can't tell you how many
people have interviewed that's another
respect in which we're different i don't
oh my no you don't i'm telling well your
interest is different than my interest
is but my interest is i i want to i want
to suck as much wisdom from you as
possible because that's the edge in life
i pray for four things courage
wisdom tolerance understanding but
for for for me like i have a painting of
my in the club room you know who's in
the club room everybody in the painting
that i have i'm in it plus seven other
people the seven other people that are
in it none of them are here all right
let me ask you a question yes let me ask
you a question go forward what kind of
answer would satisfy you coming from my
lips you don't have to be specific just
in general i would tell you what kind of
answer would satisfy me
the answer that is the most uh
thought out answer
and as real as possible i'm not looking
for an answer that i want to hear that's
not my style i'm a leader i'm not i'm
not soft i'm strong i'm looking for an
answer for you to give to say
here's where my generation screwed up
okay
if i had it my way as much as i'm
somebody that's a that's agnostic i do
think
faith plays a very important role or
maybe it's not maybe it's
we got soft because you know we didn't
pay attention to the xyz and we should
have you know i noticed america kind of
went this direction they try to be too
much like europe and they shouldn't have
america was the leader they try to be
like i don't know what it is but
whatever's in your mind to say here's
what i would pass down to you because
you said the you said weak leaders your
generation i did not say it you said you
said your dad is the
epitome of a leader where your son was
born in 1973
if you're going to be a man's man look
at my look at your grandpa and i agree
that's a man's man right but i'm asking
you what can we learn from what you've
seen so we don't screw this [ __ ] up
because i got four kids i got a ten
eight and a five-year-old and a
nine-month-old you just saw the
five-year-old in here my daughter was in
a podcast running around
i want to learn from you sincerely i
want to learn from you so i don't screw
it up myself all i can tell you is i've
been out of country for 25 years now my
experience has all been centered in
france coming back regarding the united
states
it seems to me on the one hand an
enormous amount of energy is present in
the united states an enormous amount of
exhilaration enormous amount of optimism
strangely enough
and at the same time
i can see very clearly they're all
consuming social divisions cultural and
social divisions
all right i see it are you asking me for
a diagnosis and the respect in which my
generation made decisions that led to
this well sure that's inevitably true
the generation that came to power in the
1960s witnessed a collapse of authority
that's unmistakably true a collapse of
political moral intellectual social and
sexual authority and that has
reverberated
for this exceeding 50 years there's no
question about that we're still living
with decisions
made in the 1960s say the period between
1962 and 1971 1972 when tendencies
acquired a certain fixity of direction
but that's not necessarily to say
anything about a generation screwing up
because that inculpates a generation in
something they did deliberately
and i think the
the fundamental facts of the 1960s is
not that anyone did anything
deliberately but they were all victims
of a process of interior collapse not
the first time in the 20th century we've
seen that
i mean you can go to france and
say the
1930s and see a very similar dynamic at
work
so no i don't think it's a question that
my generation or the baby boomer
generation screwed up
but that
at a certain period of time
a great many contingencies occurred
simultaneously
the wars of indo-chinese succession
preceding a pace no matter what the
americans did or thought socially and
culturally
the assassination of jfk which no one
expected which disrupted the political
continuity
of american life the ascension to power
of lyndon johnson who was a magnificent
domestic politician
but very inexperienced in foreign policy
the progressive aging of a foreign
policy establishment that successfully
fought the second world war and
navigated the cold war with the russians
in the 1950s
the fact that there was an enormous
increase in young people aged 15 to 25
is the result of the end of the second
world war that's why they were called
the baby boomer generation
the fact that every time there's an
enormous cohort population cohort a
bulge in the population
there's bound to be some sort of strife
fraternal strife social strife
because every new generation needs to be
disciplined and domesticated the larger
the generation the more difficult it is
to enforce the authority of the previous
generations all these things came
together in the 1960s nobody intended
that they came together they come
together they did come together
and we are living with the repercussions
ever since in addition to all that
the 1960s was a continuation of an
historical process that goes back at
least to
the french revolution that is the
increasing secularization
of the social order the withdrawal of
established institutions of religion for
example the catholic church in france
but the protestant clergy in the united
states as well and you can trace it out
step by step
if you look at english poetry from 1820
to 1850 you can see an ark
1820 you have someone like lord byron
saying the assyrian came down like a
wolf on the fold and his cohorts were
gleaming in purple and gold and the poem
is about the destruction of the syrian
army the palmetto at po men's the famine
you talk about the famine no the
destruction of sanakari you've got it um
and the might of the gentile on smote by
the sword hath withered like snow in the
glance of the lord now this is a flimsy
poem it's not a great piece of poetry
the date is 1822 and byron could write
in the expectation that every one of his
readers would understand that he was
participating in what was still a
christian society
it may not have been a completely
committed christian society but the
architecture was as plain as the
architecture of notre dame
you go 30 years into the future
it's not a long time
you have matthew arnold writing dover
beach
he says amma oh my beloved let us be
true to one another for the world which
lies about us like a land of dreams
hath neither really joy nor light nor
life nor certitude nor peace nor health
from pain
and we are on as uh as on a darkling
plane swept by confused alarms of
struggle and flight where ignorant
armies clash by night that's a
completely different world view byron
could not have understood that he's
talking about the melancholy long
withdrawal of faith from the european
continent
now 30 years you see a change a dramatic
change in the dire patient of european
life
and you can you can continue that right
through to t.s eliot wh arden philip
larkin
the decline has been
not necessarily linear but it's been
inexorable so all these things play a
role in talking about when i talk about
the generation
that came just after me the baby boomer
generation i don't think any lessons can
be learned for what are historical
necessities
what we see is
a great many contingencies occurring at
the same time roughly the same 10-year
period and then bang a lot of different
trajectories set as if they were canals
canals dividing the sand
that's very different i can talk until
i'm blue in the face about the
collapse of authority which i witnessed
myself in the universe in a university
setting i saw all the people i respected
deeply for example crumble in the face
of student protests just crumble
i saw that at columbia i saw that at
princeton i saw that at stanford unless
it's stamped but i saw it at berkeley as
well berkeley of course and um
you know you have um pig ignorant people
like mario savio savio at berkley
getting up on top of a car and
denouncing a system which was in every
every respect one of the glories of
american democracy the california
university system
and the university officials i was right
there i watched them say yeah yeah
you're right you're right
bow down low scrape the ground with
their nose
and all that i could think of at the
time and a few other people thinking the
same thing
how dismal to see this great tongue fall
so low as to lick the dust if you
enjoyed this short clip click over here
to watch another short clip and if you
want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]